foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman it's
the most wonderful time
it's always the Most Wonderful Time of
the Year coming up today on this free
public minimal episode we're talking to
some listeners about clinging to books
as well as some writing tips and
Publishing tips for aspiring writers we
also have an outstanding lightning round
segment and a listener tip for you you
can check out the full two and a half
hour maximal edition of episode 375
where we answer four times the questions
and dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalist or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with a
car if you have a question or comment
for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Cat on YouTube
Kathmandu says why do people hold on to
books that they'll never read again I
helped my sister move from a two-bedroom
Cottage into a one-bedroom duplex and
she insisted on taking boxes and boxes
of books with her now she has to rent a
storage locker for all the Overflow oh
isn't a storage locker just a Purgatory
for stuff yes it is I was I was thinking
the best storage locker for books though
might be like the library oh
hey tweet that yeah right the best
storage facility for books is the
library yeah I like that yeah isn't that
nice too because then you can obviously
you can donate books anywhere if you're
no longer using them but the fundamental
aspect of this question is why do people
cling the books that they will never
read or that they will never read again
coming up later on the private podcast
we're doing the home tour segment and I
took a photo of my office and you get to
see my book collection you get to see
every book that I own
and one of the things that I do is I
limit the amount of books I could bring
into my home because I have just one
bookshelf and anytime I want to bring a
new book into my home what happens I
have to remove a book from that shelf
because I just don't have the space for
it and what happens is
when we hold on to books because we have
the space for them if we have the space
for them we feel compelled to then fill
up the space with more and more books
the only reason I hold on the books now
is a if it's on my reading list I'm
going to read it in the not too distant
future so ideally within the next 90
days or if it's a book that I regularly
reference so my favorite author is David
Foster Wallace I often go and I will
reference a book of his I'll read a
chapter from one of his books that I've
read a bunch of times so I keep those
books because I actually use them of
course I have some writing books as well
that I reference for my how to write
better writing class and these are like
textbooks that I'll use for grammar or
for parts of speech especially if I'm
teaching lessons on on how to write
better YouTube channel I'll use these
books so I can teach these lessons
because I'm not a grammarian I'm not a
lexicographer but I don't need to be if
I have just a small select group of
resources I can go back to time and time
again however we lie to ourselves I tell
myself I will read that book someday so
I better hold on to it just in case yeah
and that's a trap just in case there's
always a trap especially with books
because you can tell yourself a story
I'm going to read that someday but then
someday never arrives and the only thing
that arrives is another bookshelf
because I need somewhere to put all
these books that I'm never going to read
one last thing I'll say
before I became a minimalist
I had about 2 000 books some of which I
actually read
most of them I hadn't now why did I have
them well every time I would go to a
bookstore I'd buy a stack of books
because all this one looks interesting
this one looks interesting this one
looks interesting sound familiar yeah it
happens right because your intention is
to read the book right of course I want
to read this but what is what was the
other part of my intention I want to
look smart oh yeah and how smart will I
look if you come to my house and I've
got a giant bookshelf full of all of
these impressive books well look how
impressive I am as a person
no it's far more impressive to stop
clinging to let go you know what would
look really impressive if you just had a
bookshelf and all it had I had was
Infinite Jest on there by David Foster
Wallace well that book's on a lot of
shelves but very few people I've met
have ever read it yeah but it's funny
because people keep keep it on their
shelves though because it is one of
those books that's like
um you know uh very different from other
works very hard to understand but it's
looked at as like a um you know you're
an intellectual if you can get through
uh Infinite Jest I remember Josh was
getting rid of a copy one time and I'm
like oh I'm gonna try and do it he's
like don't man don't do it he's like
you're not ready you're not ready man
yeah it's one of my favorite books I'd
never recommend it to anyone yeah I
certainly wouldn't batter someone by by
buying it as a gift for them either it
looks like a phone book and it's a
million words so it's a it's a is it a
legit million words yeah oh wow man yeah
your average book's about 60 000 words
by the way yeah no it's a very thick
dance book for sure for sure several
hundred pages of endnotes alone you know
I find a my shelf like half the books I
have on there which are in the home tour
I did like a couple weeks ago yeah yeah
um they are our
um foreign translations of our other
books yeah and that's like the one thing
that um I probably do collect a little
bit because like I love the different
styles that the different countries go
with yeah um but again I have like my
container of here are the books that you
know here's the amount of books I'm
allowed to keep it's uh the bookshelf
that I got off of you I can even fit a
couple board games on there because um I
don't have that many books but yeah half
of those books I have though are
definitely like the foreign translations
of our book yeah and so TK it's not
wrong to own books is that is that like
narcissistic of me to like keep those
books no I keep one I keep one copy of
of each foreign translation as well I
look at it as art like I I see wow it's
amazing that we have several dozen
languages that our books are published
in now yeah and a lot of them I can't
even read the characters because it's in
Japanese or it's in Korean and it's just
impressive but it looks like a work of
art it does yeah and so yeah I'll hold
on to those books but I don't have 10
copies of each either and I think what
is important here to understand is that
it's not wrong to have books the problem
with books is book clutter well what is
clutter clutter is when anything gets in
the way and so if I have books that are
getting in the way well what does that
mean they can literally physically get
in the way I remember when I was moving
I had those 2 000 books Ryan you'll
probably remember this I had a box of
books and I jumped down from the truck
bed your truck bed oh yeah I threw my
back out because what a metaphor the
stuff literally
made me throw my back out
I'm I'm hurting myself with stuff and
that is when I realized like
oh I don't need to hold on to all of
these some of them I've read and I'm not
if I'm honest with myself I'm not going
to read them again so I can let those go
yeah and there are others that if I'm
honest with myself I'm not actually
going to read that or yes if I really
want to read it in the future if I make
the mistake of getting rid of it and I
do want to read it the public library is
right down the street I can go check it
out if I want to or if I absolutely want
to repurchase it I can do that as well
do you remember the um the gentleman who
came to one of our live podcast events
so this guy came uh to uh one of our
events he's asking a question and his
question was I have about a thousand
articles bookmarked on my you know
Chrome or Safari whatever he he was
using and he was like it really stresses
me out because they are all all things
that I'm genuinely interested in but I
haven't read any of them and the sheer
amount of of what's bookmarked there
like it's overwhelming so he really
doesn't go and read a lot anyway because
it's too overwhelming and I was like man
I would like challenge you to just like
delete all of those links yeah and see
how you feel and I was like you know
don't do it if you don't want to do it
I'm like you know I'm not trying to
pressure into anything but I would like
challenge you to consider that yeah and
uh he's like yeah I will consider that
he sits down and then um he got back up
a couple questions later he's like I
just deleted all those links and he's
like he's like I cannot tell you how
freeing a freeing it was he's like this
weight was instantly lifted off my
shoulders yes and what you're talking
about is that was clutter he had
bookmark clutter it was getting in the
way not physically but mentally and
that's the other place in which all of
these books get in the way yeah
physically I can throw out my back or
it's just taking up too much space it
doesn't look great and it's also though
creating all this mental clutter the
emotional clutter the psychological
clutter and also the burden we start
worrying like oh I'm not reading enough
ironically when I got rid of those 2000
books I began reading more yeah because
the Clutter wasn't in the way preventing
me from reading yeah it is crazy how the
literal clutter of those links prevented
him from ever going to that folder and
reading the links but to start over with
a fresh start like yeah I could see
where that would be yeah more
encouraging to read that's so good this
question makes me think of a moment in
the office where Michael Scott says to
the character Toby who he hates so much
why are you the Way You Are
this question is a variation of that
right why are you the way you are and
the first thing I want to say is anytime
you can take another person's philosophy
or practice
and mock it make it look completely
stupid and say I'll get anybody possibly
believe that or do that
it only proves that you don't really
understand the philosophy or practice
sometimes we say things like I will
never understand people who say this I
will never understand people who do that
and we put that out there as if it's a
signal of nobility or virtue when in
reality it's a weakness not a strength
we should always strive for more clarity
and more understanding even about those
things with which we disagree hey I
don't endorse what they do I don't agree
with what they do but I totally get it I
can understand why a person would be
triggered to do that I can understand
why a person would be incentivized to do
that because that understanding puts you
in a position where you can be
empathetic not for the sake of saying
you're empathetic but that empathy gives
you influence because it allows you to
speak to people not from a higher up
place of being on the pulpit lording
over them but speak to them as an ally
as a person that's truly supportive of
their success the next thing I'll say is
that when it comes to books or anything
else Letting Go isn't just about the
stuff that we need to cell it's also
about the stories we tell anytime you
let go of anything it can be a person it
can be a possession it can be a place
anytime you say goodbye you're also
choosing to completely walk away from
those aspects of your life that were
oriented around whoever or whatever
you're saying goodbye to and that means
you got to learn how to tell a different
story and so it's important to be
gracious to people who are grieving a
loss or struggling to say goodbye to
something even if you look at it and say
well that relationship's toxic anyway or
that book isn't even that important
because there's a story behind what
they're trying to let go of and that
story is holding their lives together in
some kind of way and if you can engage
that story with curiosity you can help
them evolve that story but you can't
help someone evolve a story that you
yourself don't understand so instead of
saying hey why won't you let that thing
go you can say why is it here in the
first place why did that thing ever
matter to you and what is it holding
together other in your life and once you
hear that story you might surprise
yourself and say oh don't throw that
away hang on to it because if that
person tells you I got a thousand bucks
because I'm opening up a used Bookshop
you wouldn't want them to get rid of it
you say hold on to it that's value
Capital right so that story might make
you say hang on to it or the story might
make you say yeah I still think you need
to let it go but now I understand
how to help you do that in a way that's
conducive to the role that it's played
in your life you can only help a person
tell a new empowering story
when you stop condemning them forever
having the old one in the first place
what I'm hearing here
has a lot to do with letting go if it's
getting in the way let it go if you have
a book or a collection of books that are
getting in the way it's okay to let them
go if you have a living room full of
excess stuff a closet with too many
t-shirts or pairs of pants or shoes it's
okay to let it go if you have toxic
relationships in your life that are
getting in the way of your peace your
contentment your happiness it's okay to
Let It Go all of these things are
cluttered and what we want to do is not
completely eliminate all the Clutter
from our lives but understand what is
clutter and we can begin to let it go
one by one by one the reason I say
you'll never eliminate all of it is from
time to time something that serves you
today will stop serving you tomorrow so
it's not clutter today
but the thing that is serving you today
might be clutter tomorrow so we have to
keep questioning we have to figure out
what that story is because the story we
told ourselves before about the thing
isn't necessarily the true story today
and therefore it's okay to let go we
have a question from Instagram Stephen
has something for us I have been an
aspiring writer for some time and your
15 ways to write better ebook and how to
write better YouTube channel have given
me the final push to actually get
started after accumulating a bunch of
ideas in a notebook I'm finally turning
them into a book once the book is done
and I'm happy with it how do I go about
getting it published
first off Stephen congratulations on
finally getting up the courage to sit in
the chair to do the writing itself
you're no longer an aspiring writer
you're actually writing uh folks who are
listening to this if you want to check
out the free ebook it's called Uh 15
ways to write better that's what he's
talking about it's just how to
writebetter.org you can download it for
free and then the YouTube channel he's
talking about is youtube.com how to
write better I do some pre lessons over
there I also teach you a four week
writing class and in there the fourth
week we talk about publishing but let's
just say this don't get ahead of
yourself now I know the reason you're
asking this question is because you're
looking toward the Horizon and we often
want to have the perfect life the
perfect book The Perfect publication and
you're so worried about the outcome that
you forget about the process I will tell
you this Stephen the most joyous part of
writing a book is not publishing the
book in fact there's a whole lot that
goes into publishing the book where
that's the business the administrative
side the formatting the alpha readers
the beta readers going through the
editing process and cover design all
those things can be fun and joyous and
exciting but the most joyous part of
writing sitting down in that chair
and focusing and losing sight of the
rest of the world because that Story
begins to come alive on the page or that
blog post becomes alive on the page you
can sit down what TK does with his tweet
storms there that's not just poetic and
beautiful
it's communicative and expressive but
also what you do TK is I can tell how
focused you are on something this is a
writing exercise for you that you use
Twitter to express yourself and it's
just another medium I don't care where
and by the way that's publishing what
what is publishing I mean in fact even
on Twitter there's a little button that
says publish right yeah and so same with
the blog whenever we post a blog post it
says publish now we think about
publishing it's how do I find a
traditional publisher and then how do I
go through the nine months of all the
rigmarole of once my book is handed in
yeah I get it that's what a lot of
people want but as an author
this is a great term my friend Colin
Wright coined he's a authorpreneur I
like that I like that because yes it is
important for you to promote your book
to get it out there you write to be read
there's no question about that otherwise
you'd just be keeping a journal
which is fine too yeah but that's not
what we're talking about here what we're
talking about is writing for publication
but there's so many different ways to be
read now that doesn't involve going the
traditional route in fact Ryan and I
have four books together I also wrote a
novel and um those four books three of
them are independently published and
there's a difference between
self-publish and independently published
we started our own Publishing Company
back in 2012 with Colin Wright
asymmetrical press we publish books for
nine different authors it was a
beautiful experiment we don't still
publish books for other authors but we
learned a lot about that in fact we
wrote an entire six part series called
how to publish an indie book and the way
I look at it is sort of like a garage
band versus an indie rock band
self-publishing is like fine it's just a
garage band you're in there with your
friends and you're just jamming right
Indie publishing is doing all the same
stuff that a a major publisher would do
all the quality control the distribution
all of those things but doing it on an
independent level doing it on your own
and it's incredibly rewarding and we've
gone through traditional Publishers for
all of our foreign books obviously but
also for our last book A lot of people
use things and what I learned from that
process even though I really enjoyed the
book I don't like being beholden to
Major Publishers yeah and I I don't see
a world in which I continue to do that I
much rather go the independent route and
retain ownership control and the
flexibility of doing it on my own yeah
yeah by the way I'll put a link to that
series how to publish an indie book in
the show notes you can find the show
notes at the minimalists.com podcast if
you're interested in reading about the
entire Soup To Nuts process
yeah you know uh and if you do go a
traditional publishing route uh it's
important to keep in mind that that
Publishers look for evidence of momentum
sometimes when we're in the middle of
the creative process we want to wait
until we have something really beautiful
and then we can show it with the world
because the last thing we want is for
people to see the messiness of our
creative process but it can be very
helpful to adopt some form of a working
out loud so that you are teasing it out
and letting the audience know something
good is coming something cool is coming
so that by the time you drop it people
have been prepared for it and when
Publishers evaluate your book they can
look you up and they can say oh here's
someone who has some momentum they're
already doing cool stuff saying cool
things we're not going to be the only
ones doing the work of marketing this
they already have an audience they
already have a habit of putting
themselves and their work out there
lastly I think of the words of Zig
Ziglar who said sales is a transference
of filling anytime you're promoting
something the way you feel about it is
going to affect the attitude of the
people you're promoting it to more than
anything else so one of the best things
you can do to get that work published is
to actually write something that you
feel passionate about everyone says to
the point of it being a meme I hate
sales what that really means is I hate
pushing products on people that they
don't want and that I don't believe in I
hate feeling like I'm twisting other
people's arms to get them to buy
something that I and they know they
don't actually need but when it comes to
recommending things that we believe in
everybody turns into a salesperson then
you see a movie that blows your mind you
read a book that's amazing you eat a
meal that's delicious what do you do you
grab your friend by the arm and you say
yo you gotta you gotta check out this
place you gotta read this book you gotta
watch that movie and that feeling
transfers and so if you want to sell
well don't focus on the money don't
focus on the I need people to read my
book so I can pay my bills write
something that makes you feel like ah I
can't wait for the world to read this oh
man I'm so excited everybody needs to
read this even if I got to give out a
few copies because that feeling will
ultimately transfer and you'll be like
that teacher in school who even though
they teach a boring subject makes
everybody pay attention because they're
fired up about it that's the best gift
you can give to the world yeah I mean
yeah I love what you're saying because
um I think we're all selling something
the question is is what are you selling
and do you believe in it I remember our
first uh books book tour stop um in
Orlando we were with a bunch of uh couch
Surfers and one of an awesome group it
was and someone asked a question and we
were torn with minimalism of a
meaningful life and he asked a question
and I was like you know what I was like
I'm going to give you like a high level
I'm like and but I'm not trying to like
sell you anything man I'm like but you
know in our book wig we literally write
exactly about what you're talking about
you know much more in depth you might
find Value in that book and he's like
why are you so trepidatious to sell your
own book man and I'm like I just don't
want you to feel like I'm pushing
something on you he's like but if you
believe in it like it's okay to to be
excited about something that you truly
believe in and it's shifted my whole
context like I mean just that first tour
stop thank God because we've been on a
million tour stops since then that's
right um but yeah it's all about like
yeah what are you selling because we're
all selling something for sure and how
do you feel about that thing that you're
creating if you're just wishy-washy it's
why I don't have a problem talking about
our books on this podcast
and the reason I don't have a problem
with it is because these are books that
I believe in that yeah we put our Blood
Sweat and Tears and and oftentimes spent
a year plus on a book with a lot of
people use things it was over two years
writing that book and so I feel great
about the book and yes I write to be
read it doesn't mean that I think you
should read the book but if this topic
interests you
that's exactly why I wrote this because
if I could simply like Ryan if I could
answer the question in one paragraph
then I wouldn't write the book you write
a book because you have something more
to say yeah and I think that's key for
Stephen anyone else is considering
writing is sometimes it doesn't require
a book sometimes a blog post is
sufficient in fact it's better as a blog
post I've seen this quite often where
someone writes this viral article for
the Atlantic or the New Yorker and it's
awesome and they get some great
publishing deal to expand that into a
book and it's like oh no you sort of
lost the essence of the thing because
it's no longer that thing that really
resonated with people and so sometimes a
tweet will do
sometimes it takes an entire book length
project you can't do Infinite Jest in a
tweet it's a million words I could tell
you my favorite line from Infinite Jest
it's
um everything I've ever let go of has
claw marks on it yeah
yeah that's a good one Ryan what time is
it oh you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your questions from Tick Tock yes indeed
you can follow us on Tick Tock also
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalists
during the lightning round the store
Ryan and TK and I do our best to answer
questions of the short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place as well
minimalmaxims.com looks like Tatiana has
a question from Tick Tock when you talk
about developing habits for writing are
these methods specifically for writing
books or writing in general
um
well
we're gonna put some time on the clock
we got 60 seconds here
maybe we start with uh
TK Coleman
what uh what Kitty Lattimore lyrics are
you gonna quote today
I want to be a good writer listen to
Brian McKnight and read the lyrics
all my writing comes from Boyz II Men
uh let's see here okay
bad writing is the initiation ritual
into good writing when it comes to
writing the question isn't do you want
to be good or are you already good the
question is are you willing to be bad
long enough to become good I forget who
the writer was who said it but he said
something to the effect it was it was
actually whatever the writer's name is
the one who wrote Tarzan uh and also uh
the Princess of Mars but he says that
that every writer has uh thousands of
words of bad prose in their soul and
writing is the process of purifying your
soul of all the bad Pros that you have
and so whether you're writing in general
or writing a book ultimately writing
begins with a confrontation
with the truth of who we are and a
willingness to allow the world to see us
for who we are in that vulnerability in
that Honesty before we become beautiful
that's how you get beautiful it's like
being physically fit unless you're
willing to look out of shape you don't
actually get into shape
right in time C.K Coleman yeah yeah Ryan
Nicodemus you got 60 seconds what do you
got for us oh man uh my pithy answer is
this a pleasant life is composed of
unpleasant habits so it doesn't matter
if you're writing it doesn't matter if
you're playing guitar you're going to
have to put in the work to be an expert
at whatever it is that you're trying to
do so with your writing class Josh yes
it's about writing fiction it's about
writing nonfiction it's about writing
emails it's about writing you know uh
social media posts whatever it is
um if you want to be good at something
you've got to put in the work and here's
the thing about a purpose we're all
looking to to have a purpose where's my
purpose TK where's my purpose I'm need
to have a purpose as if we want to like
possess a purpose and you cannot possess
a purpose you can serve a purpose but
there is no ownership with the purpose
but here's the thing when you serve a
purpose and you serve it well that
purpose will have you and all those
unpleasant things that are a little bit
unpleasant makes them just a little bit
more pleasant when it's driven by your
the purpose you're serving oh come on
baby that was a half court shot at the
buzzer Tick Tock that Danny unknown what
I love about what you're both saying
here before you put 60 seconds on the
clock for me you're both touching on
something that I think is is crucial
here we often want to possess something
but when writing becomes another
possession
yeah well then it can become clutter
when you have to do it that's not what
we're talking about here you get to do
it however what Ryan is Illuminating
there will be resistance oh I don't feel
like sitting down in the chair today to
do the writing because there are all
these other things that are easier to do
I have all these other excuses I used to
have a checklist of 15 different things
I had to do before I started writing I
have to fold the laundry I have to make
sure the dishes are washed and then all
of these things and of course I do 13 or
14 of them but there was always
something else to do so I never actually
wrote how did I start writing
I decluttered the checklist I
decluttered the to-do's you can make
only you can make only one thing a
priority right and so writing became the
priority the first thing I do when I get
up is I write I don't have to worry
about anything else I have no other
rules the first rule is to wake up the
second rule is to write and that is it
it is that simple give me 60 seconds and
I got something pithy for you
a habit is a byproduct of doing
something compelling and so if you hate
writing I wouldn't suggest sitting down
every day to do the writing however if
you feel the resistance because you know
it's going to be a little bit more
difficult than folding the laundry I say
yes that resistance is actually a beacon
it shows you the direction in which you
want to go because if you find writing
compelling then you're also going to be
resistant to it anything that is
worthwhile you are going to experience a
little bit of resistance it's almost
like your body's saying no no no there's
something easier out here well simple
ain't easy but it is simple to get up
every day to sit in that chair for one
hour put the words on the page stare at
that blinking line
and do the actual writing I don't care
about you being a writer I just want to
see you writing
yeah baby mama said simple ain't easy no
no it ain't no it ain't you know what
you were talking about makes me think
about
um our really good friend Matt diabella
who directed uh both of our
documentaries
um remember he because he wanted to uh
talk about his version of minimalism and
talk about his story and remember like
he started a Blog yep and he was like
you know just typing away typing away
posting away and he got to a point where
he was like I don't thoroughly enjoy
this like this isn't my meeting this
isn't my medium and we're like no dude
like you're a film guy like that's your
medium so that's when you know he
started his YouTube channel and stuff
and that was so compelling to do the
video aspect that he could not do it
right and um now he is way more popular
than us
congratulations to Matthew Bella let's
check in with our patreon live stream in
a moment but first real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
since we're talking so much about
writing today just real quick my four
week online writing class is called how
to write better I only open it two or
three times a year 48 Hours only 100
students only it opens up February 17th
so mark your calendars if you head on
over to how to write better.org put your
email address in there we'll notify you
when the course opens you can be one of
the 100 people who sign up for that it's
only open for 48 hours and you can
interact with the other students and
it's an interactive class four weeks and
we will show you how to build the
writing habit how to write how to
rewrite there's a whole week on editing
and there's a whole week on publishing
as well how to write better.org for more
details let's check in with the patreon
live stream Alabama what do you got for
us we've got a question here from Amy
she says clinging to books is a very
timely topic I made a first pass at my
bookshelf over the weekend I know I have
more to release but I'm not sure where
to go with them calling the local
library is a on my to-do list but what
other ways can I intentionally give away
my books hmm I'd say how I do it
typically is I will go to those free
local libraries the neighborhood
libraries little libraries yes adore
those the little libraries yeah remember
when our last book came out Ryan a lot
of people use things and we did uh these
little libraries I think in 200 cities
across Across America yeah and we even
autographed some books and went and put
it in like people did a scavenger hunt
to try to find Advanced copies of love
people using things yeah that was fun I
love the little neighborhood little
libraries and there are websites in fact
I don't remember off top my head but
we'll have podcast Sean put a link to
there's a website that shows you or the
closest Little library is to your home
so they're just these like giant mailbox
looking things they usually have a
see-through window and and there are a
bunch of books in there well quite often
they get depleted really quickly and so
you can donate your books to your your
neighborhood and so your community can
now get value from those books I picked
one up the other day from maybe about
two weeks ago it was a Kafka book The
Metamorphosis and I was like I haven't
read Kafka since like my mid-20s and I
was able to dive back in I was just
walking by it and I saw it it caught my
eye and there it was and so you can
declutter but also add value to other
people's lives whether it's donating to
the library selling books to your local
bookstore that's another place that I do
a local bookstore up in Ojai yeah they
have they allow you to sell your books
to them now you don't get a whole lot
but I saw a bunch of books enough to buy
one used book from them and I'm not
spending any money yeah what did we do
when we were up there we have like a
first line battle oh yeah like a random
book that's one of my favorite things to
do I go to a bookstore with friends and
we'll just grab a book off the shelf and
we we read the first line and something
I teach in the writing class called
narrative urgency does this first line
make me want to read the second line and
if so that's a great first line but a
lot of first lines are like oh in fact
we did a video put a link to this in the
show notes uh Bill Clinton's boring the
first one yeah and it came from that
that trip up to the bookstore up in Ojai
it did you remember the line
no it's so boring but I remember the
line I remember how I would have
Rewritten it and so he talks about in
1944 I was born in a beige uh just like
it's all communication no expression he
talked but he was born in Hope Arkansas
think about this here's a great first
line for
or Bill Clinton it's
on whatever the date was on December
14th 1944 I was born on the outskirts of
Hope yes
that's oh yeah man here's the thing
though no no serious stinker or writer
ever dreams of sounding like someone
who's running for office
because when you're running for office
you got to neutralize yourself and be as
universally appealing and offensive as
possible I'm not arbitrarily hating this
isn't the anti-government
you gotta always appear polished and you
can't admit what kind of music you
really like you gotta hide behind
classical and jazz because it has the
least amount of obviously offensive con
you know content nobody's gonna be like
you know my favorite musical artist is
you know Eminem or something like that
if they're running for office even if
they really believe that so this goes
back to you got to bring your
personality to it and not just follow
prescriptions you hear it in public
speeches all the time I mean how many
public speeches have you heard where
it's like
we live in a society that you know in
the year 1955 it's like come on give me
you give me you do something that could
possibly be wrong yes you know no that's
a good observation like you got to be
more vanilla when you're yeah running
for office and I guess that translates
to the book but it doesn't make the book
compelling and if you start the book
with I was born on the outskirts of Hope
yeah oh I want to read the next line and
I think that's what compelling writing
does it propels you to the second line
the second line propels you to the third
so forth and so on we'll get back to the
patreon live stream here in a little bit
but first from Alabama what do you got
for us here's the minimalist Insight
from one of our listeners
hi fellow minimalists I just wanted to
leave this tip because it has been a
recent shift in my way of thinking on
the podcast when I used to hear people
or even Josh and Ryan discussing like
consuming consciously and thinking about
the companies where they purchase things
I felt like that was too much work to do
the research behind companies and
recently I've kind of realized that my
power in a way comes from the things
that I'm spending my money on in our
current society and so it actually seems
like a very small price to pay to do the
research and purchase products from
places that care about the environment
and that treat their employees well
because I suppose the alternative is
spending money on
goods and places that maybe don't care
about their employees and don't treat
the environment well and then if I am
purchasing from them then in a way I am
supporting those behaviors which don't
align with my values
all right y'all that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see on patreon
for the full two and a half hour maximal
edition of episode 375 which includes
four times as many questions from our
listeners a private minimalist home tour
our obsolete object segment of course
TK's tweet of the week got outstanding
added value segment for you as well as
well as an argument with one of our
listeners TK sets them straight don't
worry
plus you get access to all of our
archives over there on patreon all the
way back to episode zero zero one and
much much more of less and if you want
to hear all that patreon.com
the minimalist that's where you find the
minimalist private podcast
subscribe you'll get your personal link
so our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app all right y'all can
leave here today with just one message
let it be this love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it